CLEVE MOLER: The Lorenz
strange attractor, perhaps
the world's most
famous and extensively
studied ordinary
differential equations.
They were discovered in
1963 by an MIT mathematician
and meteorologist,
Edward Lorenz.
They started the field of chaos.
They're famous because
they are sensitive
to their initial conditions.
Small changes in the
initial conditions
have a big effect
on the solution.
Lorenz is famous for talking
about the butterfly effect.
How flapping of butterflies'
wings can affect the weather.
A butterfly flying in
Brazil can cause a tornado
and Texas is a flamboyant
version of a talk he gave.
The equations are almost linear.
There's two
quadratic terms here.
The equations come out
of a model of fluid flow.
The Earth's
atmosphere is a fluid.
But this range of parameters,
the three parameters, sigma,
rho, and beta, these
are outside the range
that actually represents
the Earth's atmosphere.
We're going to take a
look at these parameters.
These are the most
commonly used parameters.
But we're going to be interested
in other values of rho as well.
But I'm a matrix guy,
so I like to write
the equations in this form.
Y dot equals Ay.
It looks linear except
A depends upon y.
And so there's y2, the
second component of y,
appears in the matrix A.
This helps me study the
differential equations
in this form.
This matrix form is
convenient for finding
the critical points.
Put a parameter
eta in place of y2.
Try to make the matrix singular.
That happens when eta is beta
times the square root of rho
minus 1.
And then the null vector
is the critical point.
If we take this vector as the
starting value of the solution,
then the solution stays there.
Y prime is 0.
This is an unstable
critical point.
And values near this solution
deviate the solution.
Won't stay near the solution.
In May of 2014, I wrote a series
and blog post in Cleve's Corner
about the MATLAB ordinary
differential equations suite.
And I used the Lorenz
attractor as an example.
And I included a program
called Lorenz plot
that I'd like to use here.
Here's Lorenz plot.
Set the parameters.
Set the initial value
of the matrix A.
Here is the critical point.
Here is an initial value
near the critical point.
Integrate from 0 to 30.
Use ODE 23.
Give it a function called
the Lorenz equation.
Capture the values t and y
and then plot the solution.
I'm going to do a plot with
the three components offset
from each other.
And here's an internal
function Lorenz equation
that is called by ODE 23.
And it continuously,
every time it called,
it modifies the matrix A updates
it with the new values of y2.
So let's run that function.
And here's the output.
Here is the three components
of the Lorenz attractor.
Time series is functions of t.
It's pretty hard to see
what's going on here
except to say they start out
with their initial values,
oscillate around
them, close them
through for a little while,
and then begin to deviate.
And it's hard to see
what they're doing.
They're just oscillating in
an unpredictable fashion.
We need another graphic to see
what's really going on here.
I want to write a program
called Lorenz GUI.
Lorenz Graphic User Interface.
That's out of my old book
calle this one is really
out of Numerical Computing
with MATLAB, NCM.
OK, I hit the Start button.
Here are the two
critical points in green.
We started near
the critical point.
We oscillate around
And here is the orbit.
This is just going
back and forth.
It oscillates around
one critical point then
decides to go over and oscillate
around the other for a while.
It continues around
like this forever.
This is not periodic.
It never repeats.
Now, the butterfly is associated
with Lorenz in two ways.
One is the butterfly
effect on the weather.
Also, this plot looks
like a butterfly.
I can grab this with
my mouse and rotate it
in three dimensions.
So I can get different
views of the orbit.
It's still being computed.
We're adding more
and more to the plot.
And I can look at it from
different points of view
to get some notion
of how this is
proceeding in three dimensions.
It almost lives in two
dimensions, but not quite.
Earlier, we've seen solutions,
differential equations
with periodic solutions.
Here, this isn't periodic.
Just going like this
[? forever. ?] Now,
this is perfectly--
this isn't random.
This is completely determined
by the initial conditions.
If I were to start it over again
with those exact conditions,
with those exact
initial conditions,
I'd get exactly this behavior.
But it's unpredictable.
It's hard to say
where this is going.
I can clear this out and see
the orbit continue to develop.
Press Stop.
Now I have a choice.
This pull down
menu here allows me
to choose other values of rho.
28 is the value of rho that
is almost always studied,
but there's a book
by a Colin Sparrow
that I've referenced in my in
my blog about periodic solutions
to Lorenz equations.
And let's take another value.
Let me choose rho equal to
160 and clear and restart.
Now, after an initial
transient, this is now periodic.
So this is not chaos.
This is a periodic solution.
And these other
values of rho, not rho
equals 28, that's chaotic,
but these other values of rho
give periodic solutions
with different character.
That's a long,
interesting story that I
talk about in my blog
following the work of Sparrow.